[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
nous sommes venus vous raconter notre
histoire et tu te souviens je flippe
mais quand elle commence cette histoire
elle commence une de ses soirées à aix
en provence
dse une soirée de fin d'été où il fait
encore chaud et doux j'avais tout juste
17 ans et c'était en septembre 2008
je me rappelle que cette heure en
septembre 2008 parce que ce mois là tous
les journaux titraient que le monde
rentrait dans une crise une crise
systémique dont l'épicentre était
américain est allé gagner la planète
entière
le monde est en crise mais moi j'étais
insouciant
j'étais fier de mes premiers bars sainte
de celle qu'on appelle tous les deux
l'école de la république
j'ai été exaltée par mes premières
heures de liberté et d'autonomie
loin du foyer familial ce soir-là
déserte ma chambre d'étudiant pour aller
rejoindre les copains restaurants
universitaires des gazelles est celui-là
plateau à la main avec olivier notre ami
resté comment depuis 10 ans déjà il me
désigne ta table je balaie du regard
je te regarde il découvre la colossale
envergure ta gueule un peu cassée ta
mine renfrognée pour ceux qui te
connaissent pas et on superbe labrador
noir qui te flanque tout le temps
et c'est pas deux labradors noirs qui
fait que qu'on va l'argent philippe ce
soir là même si lille est
authentiquement mignon pas vrai non ce
qui fait nous allons vers toi ce soir là
c'est le sens de la différence c'est le
goût de l'autre c'est l'envi de braver
les apparences ne dit on pas qu'on ne
voit bien qu'avec le coeur parce que
l'essentiel est invisible pour les yeux
est ce que mon jeune choeur à moi vois
ce soir là c'est une âme une âme
sensible largement introspectif et déjà
passionnément engagé une âme avec
laquelle il entrait en résonance est
possible et moi assis à ma table au self
que je fréquente et tous les soirs en
amateur de grande gastronomie
j'entends arrivé un soir dans le
brouhaha des étudiants aux affamés deux
jeunes de notre école qui sont en
première année quand pour ma part je
suis en 4e année et j'ai toujours aimé
partager mon expérience mon vécu afin de
faciliter pour les plus jeunes leur
propre chemin
ou en tout cas essayer et donc ce soir
là on se retrouve avec un ancien est de
nouveau un handicapé et deux valides est
un passionné technologies et deux
disques artistique qui se retrouvent au
cours de ce repas mémorables avec l'idée
de s'écouter de s'enrichir de leurs
différences et réunis par une seule et
même vibration profondément humaine
alors leur voix s'entremêlent puis
s'harmonisent puis
c'est le début d'une grande aventure
humaine issue d'une écoute mutuelle et
comme le la de toute aventure étudiante
on commence par refaire la politique la
société des écoles
bref pas rêver rêver d'un monde à
l'unisson je me souviens que assez vite
tu me pose la question comment ça se
passe mon handicap et comment je le gère
et j'ai toujours pensé qu' il faut
raconter ce qu'on vit pour le banaliser
pour enlever les peurs qu'il suscite et
fantasmes qu'ils génèrent alors je
montre je raconte
j'explique et notamment je t'explique
mon rapport à l'informatique avec tout
ce que ça m'apporte et ses limites aussi
notamment pour accéder aux livres un peu
plus tard j'invite corentin dans la
suite de 9 m² une suite étudiante
remarquables et ils découvrent tout le
monde na tsy rails et comprend à quel
point le son est la clé pour la
communication avec l'extérieur et aussi
avec mon ordinateur
parce que c'est bien avec le son que
j'accède au traitement de texte à
l'internet via la messagerie à
l'occasion par la même occasion corps en
temps un homme lit des livres de droit
constitutionnel
première leçon de ma jeunesse la
curiosité est aussi un vilain défaut
bref la complicité s'installe à la
vitesse du son et royan jean-philippe
utiliser son outil informatique
je comprends mais tout ce que le
numérique à des révolutions jusqu'à
présent tu m'expliques les personnes
déficientes visuelles étaient
majoritairement destiné à faire de
l'accordage de piano du massage du
rempaillage et pour les plus chanceux il
est plus talentueux de la musique
et voilà que le numérique ouvre une
fenêtre sur le monde
une fenêtre sur l'autre qui vous permet
de vous affirmer dans la société de vous
insérer dans la société
et voilà aussi que le numérique vous
permet de gommer les égalités cliente
qui prévalait jusque là les inégalités
dans l'accès au travail dans l'accès à
l'information dans l'accès aux savoirs
dans nos sociétés de la connaissance
et là la passion l'égalité ne gagne je
vois dans cette promesse là dans la
promesse technologique portée par jean
philippe l'occasion de renouveler la
promesse démocratique une promesse qui
égalise des conditions entre les
personnes en situation de handicap et
les autres et cette conversation là elle
laisse des traces et on décide de mener
l enquête
je lis des rapports je me renseigne sur
le sujet ils découvrent des chiffres
édifiants que je partage avec toi
quatre personnes sur dix de plus 70 ans
disposent d'un ordinateur à la maison
peut-être direz vous ce n'est pas la
génération z pour le numérique
mais parmi celles là deux personnes sur
dix seulement déficientes visuelles sont
susceptibles est capable de mobiliser un
ordinateur pour compenser leur handicap
en réalité on se rend compte que le
numérique fait des exclus beaucoup
d'exclus et cette réalité là elle a un
nom elle s'appelle la fracture numérique
pour certains le fossé numérique pour
d'autres tout le monde en est conscient
les pouvoirs publics comme les
entreprises privées qui imaginent des
solutions mais à chaque fois ces
solutions ne sont pas à la hauteur du
phénomène et nous nous regardons en dix
ans mais que faudrait-il faire
existe-t-il un pc qui soit accessible
universellement
existe-t-il un pc qui soit susceptible
de grossir de vocaliser de personnalités
des interfaces existe-t-il un pc qui
soient fournis avec un accompagnement
humain
de ce nom de manière à ce que
l'apprentissage des usages de
l'informatique soit un itinéraire
passionnant et stimulant plutôt que
qu'un long chemin de croix
après recherches
force est d'admettre que l'ong
non nous constatons que les interfaces
proposés dans des environnements
classiques comme windows ou mac ne sont
pas suffisamment souple pour s'adapter à
tout le monde
ce système inclut des choses pour
vocaliser pour grossir bref pour
s'adapter
sauf que d'une complexité abyssal quand
on va sur les forums
très rapidement il est facile de s'en
rendre compte que l'accompagnement
n'existe pas est d'autant moins que qui
les éditeurs de logiciels ou les
concepteurs de matériel c'est pas leur
tasse de thé accompagner quelqu'un sait
l'écouter c'est s'intéresser à sa
singularité
mais c'est pas rentable ça du coup les
concepteurs invente qu'on va appeler
nous des faux fuyants
d'un côté les tablettes pour les seniors
de l'autre les d'outils domotique qui en
simplifiant à outrance l' usage de
l'informatique ont de conséquence la
restriction dans la liberté des usages
et la restriction même dans l'intimité
d'usagé de l'informatique dans notre
conception ces outils conduisent à ce
que l'informatique devienne un outil de
consommation plutôt qu'un outil
d'édition de partager au final de
création concrètement ça veut dire que
si vos parents ou vos grands-parents
même vous même d'ailleurs un jour
venaient à connaître des difficultés
visuelles et ça a des chances d'arriver
puisque entre 70 et 80 ans les gens ont
25 % de chance ou de malchance
d'ailleurs souffrir d'une des maynats
bon et bien à ce moment-là
l'informatique ne pourra rien
et pour votre autonomie cognitive tout
ça parce qu'on se refuse de dépasser la
proche produit et on se refuse de
développer scène sur l'accompagnement
qui respecte chacun dans son rythme et
dans sa méthode d'apprentissage
absolument hilarant nous nous disons six
deux jeunes passionnés de philosophie de
psychologie de sociologie de sciences
humaines et technologies ne sont pas à
même de le faire si la fougue qui est la
nôtre celle de la jeunesse n'est pas à
même de susciter la détonation capable
de mettre enfin la technologie au
service de tous et enfin qu'il fera
c'est comme cela que l'on créé hypra
hypra on l'emprunté à la racine grecque
le plus le meilleur quand toutes les
autres start up choisissent des noms
anglais et ont fait partager par
fidélité à la tradition humaniste
européenne
il pourra pour nous c'est la conviction
que la technologie quelle qu'elle soit
de venir s'inscrire dans une trajectoire
d'élévation de progrès des humains
quelle que soit leur situation
ce faisant nous inventons une nouvelle
norme en informatique un ordinateur dont
l'interface est parfaitement souple qui
dispose nativement d'être technique son
et autre reposant sur des principes
classiques standards connus de tous et
surtout avec un accompagnement humain
dès la sortie du pc du carton et le
système sur lequel nous basons ce pc il
a été en grande partie fait par des
bénévoles de la communauté du logiciel
libre
alors je prends mon sac à dos quand
j'entends aussi avec nos ordis quand
même parce que quand même et puis on va
parcourir l'europe
nous allons lui et moi en espagne en
allemagne en république tchèque et on va
rencontrer des développeurs souvent
barbus d'ailleurs
et wirth choses dans leur domaine
quoique un peu isolé dans un plutôt sur
un milieu technique mais nous essayons
de les convaincre et nous arrivons
mettons dans notre sillage le faisons
comprendre nous sensibilisons bref nous
tentons autant que possible d'orchestrer
la marche vers une informatique
universel et quand nous arrivons cela
nous permet de nous consacrer à la plus
belle de la valeur ajoutée à savoir
aider chacun chaque personne déficiente
visuelle ou fragiles ainsi que son
entourage familial ou amical à
reconquérir son autonomie et sa
communication grâce à l'informatique
alors oui adapter une solution à la
singularité de chacun personnaliser une
pédagogie en fonction du profil de
chacun être à l'écouté active met à la
disposition d'une personne et ne pas
mettre les dents au premier plan dès
qu'il ya un problème
évidemment que cela prend du temps eh
ben ce temps nous le prenons et fin 2016
nous proposons à leurs utilisateurs un
pca accès universel et après quelques
mois de travail nous en équipe ont une
centaine avec succès et surtout nous
découvrons à quel point l'universalité
et qui était l'un des m2 ce projet a du
sens qu'ils sont ensemble les solutions
de vocalisation de zoom d'aménagement de
couleurs etc
en fait elles peuvent servir à tout le
monde ça vous est jamais arrivé à vous
d'avoir en fin de journée les yeux
fatigués et de lire un texte trop petit
et du coup d'avoir envie de vesoul mais
finalement ça peut servir à tous alors
fort de notre vision universelle
cette vision qui vise à mettre le
numérique à la porte et tous
forts de notre équipe à l'époque
composée de quatre personnes dont trois
sont en situation de handicap visuel
fort de ce produit fort aussi de cette
réflexion permanente sur le service
apporté à nos utilisateurs
reposant sur une réflexion de sciences
humaines nous décidons de construire un
plan de développement et d'aller
convaincre des investisseurs
les premiers nous disent nous ne
finançons pas l'innovation nous ne
finançons pas de projets pionniers les
seconds nous disent oui mais nous ce qui
nous intéresse ce sont les projets
transhumanistes et parce que notre
projet à nous et authentiquement
humaniste nous décidons donc d'aller
voir des investisseurs d'impact c'est à
dire des investisseurs qui réduisent la
rentabilité attendue sur le capital est
qu'ils augmentent leur horizon
d'investissement pour se consacrer
précisément à l'impact social et cet
impact social personne de nous le
contexte on compense mieux à long terme
la fragilité sans faire dépenser des
fortunes à la personne ou aux
contribuables
partout on nous reçoit on nous écoute et
on ne comptera tulle bien sûr sur la
qualité de ce projet la qualité de cette
vision la qualité de cette équipe mais
tout en me disant revenez plus tard
projet est trop risqué ce faisant je
crois qu'il est temps ce soir jean
philippe de faire le deuil
nous ne finançons pas ce projet vise à
septfonds peut tout du moins pas dans
cette phase là il faut se mettre
certainement dans la tête que les fonds
d'investissement c'est un peu vous savez
comme la cavalerie corse
il vole au secours de la victoire notre
cause des congés 1
il ya vraiment de quoi se décourager non
et si ce projet s'arrêter ouais est-ce
que ce projet manquerait à une société
qui bon vieillissantes ou quand même
effectivement le numérique est devenu un
passage obligé pour effectuer l'ombre de
ces démarches administratives en même
temps acceptons une société ont la
technologie prétend se suffire à
elle-même où la technologie prétendirent
aux individus que parce qu'ils sont trop
vieux trop bête ou trop seul
ils ne peuvent pas effectuer la base de
certaines démarches citoyennes parce
qu'elles sont désormais électronique
ce que c'est acceptable ça et qu'importe
l'indifférence mesure heureuse la
frilosité face à la prise de risque le
mépris exercée sur ceux qui prétendent
positivement changé le monde
ce projet nous décidons de le poursuivre
nous décidons de poursuivre par ce qui
rend un service à la société et aux
individus parce qu'il réconcilie
l'efficacité économique et la solidarité
la fraternité et le professionnalisme
l'humain est la technique la force et la
fragilité
merci
[Applaudissements]